[Musique]
en 2018 la décision du ministère de la
forêt de la fonde et des parcs d'abolir
les quotas sur le piégeage des lynx en a
pris plusieurs par surprise il faut dire
que cette espèce avait été
presqu'entièrement décimée par les
trappeurs au siècle dernier aujourd'hui
le ministère tente d'évaluer l'impact de
cette décision prise sans un inventaire
précis des populations de lynx
[Musique]
deux employés du ministère de la forêt
de la fournée des parcs se livre à un
curieux ballet hivernal non loin de la
réserve de portneuf
ben on est rodé a pas seulement une
station sur deux on en mettra pas
partout
elle s'installe des pièges à poil
destiné à détecter la présence de lynx
dans le secteur
on a mis un corps d'acier torsadé auto
sur lequel on est venu couper quelques
branches puis quand la langue s'il va
venir se frotter sur ce poteau le il
voit l'essai du poil on suspend sa une
branche habituellement pour que ça vole
un peu dans le vent et que sa fille
s'attirer la délinquance vers notre
dispositif
[Musique]
96 dispositif comme ceux ci sont
installés dans les régions de la
capitale nationale chaudière appalaches
et l'abitibi le but de l'opération
évalué la densité de population de lynx
au québec depuis l'abolition du quota
piégeage
au siècle dernier on a intensivement
piéger le lynx roux et le lynx du canada
en raison de la valeur de leur fourrure
point culminant chez 1987 de l'ain du
canada a atteint un prix moyen de 133
dollars ça veut dire que des jeunes lynx
il y avait des prix jusqu'à 1400 dollars
par peau quand il ya des extrêmes comme
ceux il ya des abus l'eau les gens ils
couraient plus les espèces à 15,20
dollars qui ont dirigé un effort sur un
espèce qui étaient vulnérables comme le
lynx
le lynx roux en particulier a presque
été dissipées en 1991 la situation était
si critique que québec a interdit le
piégeage de l'animal pendant 20 ans
quant aux lynx du canada sont piégeage a
aussi été interdite mais pendant moins
longtemps
j'ai des collègues sont dispersés un peu
et shiloh
le trappeur pierre yves collin qui a
longtemps travaillé comme technicien au
ministère des forêts de la faune et des
parcs a été surpris en 2018
cette année-là québec a aboli les quotas
piégeage dans le cadre du nouveau plan
de gestion du lynx
au paintball comme sosa pourrait ça
pourrait être dangereux à mon sens c'est
complètement c'est un béret
je
sow un plan gestion moi je trouve que
c'est un peu audacieux plan de gestion
on parle de taux pour les orignaux
caribou le cerf de virginie parce qu'on
connaît les effectifs ont fait des
inventaires il ya aucune juridiction en
amérique du nord qui fait des
inventaires de population langue ça
n'existe pas c'est une espèce qui est
assez discrète donc c'est pas possible
de les inventorier pour être capable de
dénombrer combien d'individus
c'est la biologiste meriane chevaux qui
a suggéré la levée des quotas
elle croit que de limiter le nombre de
prises ne permettait pas d'avoir un
portrait juste de la situation
un coteau c'est une mesure qui est
efficace si et seulement si quand a
atteint le quota est capable d'arrêter
la récole d'animaux mais dans le cas de
dengue ces pôles quo parce que c'est des
animaux qui vont se prendre souvent dans
des pièges qui sont destinés à d'autres
espèces notamment les canidés les
piégeurs était tout le temps dans des
situations illégales il avait pris trop
de lynx ou en dehors de la saison du
losc mais il faisait pas exprès parce
que c'était des captures accidentelles
c'est quand on est une mesure puiqu'elle
marche pas il faut faire quelque chose
pour changer la proche
[Musique]
et pour french fries mais sa nature
une piste de lynx
[Musique]
l'appellation piste de rex malgré son
scepticisme pierre yves collet a accepté
de collaborer avec le ministère qui a
recruté des trappeurs pour effectuer le
suivi des populations de lynx support
réfractaires à collaborer avec les
autres parce que dans le fond c'est le
bien des espèces qui compte et il
demande aussi qu'on cartographie qu'on
identifie des captures qu'on fait
composition ils vont être capables de
voir dans quelle ebit au qui était
quel mot et forestières finale mais qui
semble attirer le plus souvent les lynx
8 ou donner la chance au coureur faut
aller chercher des données il ya
beaucoup de données manquantes sur ces
espèces d'eaux puiseaux dont on peut
leur en fournir
[Musique]
quatre mois après l'installation des
pièges à poil les caméras témoins
commence à livrer leurs secrets
oui
[Rires]
trop échantillon de relever des poils et
toucy couronnée de succès donc là on
voit qu'il ya langue ce qui est venu y
est arrivé par la botte et il s'est
présenté aux poteaux il s'est frotté
contre le poteau c'est ça qu'on cherche
à ramasser des poils de lynx donc c'est
une très bonne nouvelle
donc lorsqu'on va faire c'est récolter
les échantillons pour les maintenant des
petits sacs qui les faire sécher
éventuellement les envoyer en analyse
génétique dans un laboratoire spécialisé
jusqu'à présent les dispositifs ont
attiré moins de lynx dans portneuf que
dans chaudière appalaches
en abitibi on en a aperçu beaucoup plus
que dans les autres régions
avec les poils ici vont être capables
d'aller chercher l'adn qu'il est
incapable d'avoir aussi un niveau est ce
que c'est le même langue qui est revenue
[Musique]
ces deux langues différentes parce que
des fois dans les photos on voit que
vraiment d irlande fipa saison le lundi
puis un autre langue si passé le
vendredi que ses côtés aussi est ce que
c'est le même c'est un différent donc
avec l'adn stockman capable d'aller
chercher ce niveau le
québec se donne encore un an pour
compiler les données récoltées sur le
terrain pas de quoi laisser
entre temps le ministère n'a d'autre
choix que de se fier sur les
déclarations volontaires des trappeurs
pour évaluer le nombre de lynx pj durant
l'année pour l'instant ces données
indiquent que la récolte de lynx roux
est en hausse depuis l'abolition du
quota probablement en raison d'une
augmentation des populations
québec gardera donc un oeil sur cette
espèce au cours des prochaines années
quant aux lynx du canada le plus prisé
depuis toujours par les piégeurs sa
récolte n'a pas augmenté depuis
l'abolition du quota il faut dire que
sur la planète l'appétit pour la
fourrure en général et à son plus bas
c'est sûr qu'on a pris sa décision là
dans le contexte actuel on sait que le
marché de la fourrure est pas très fort
et c'est pour ce qu'on suit de près les
populations pour être capable de voir si
la situation venait à changer être
capable de rien gir et donc de prendre
des mesures qui permettraient de
s'assurer qu'on maintient les
populations
pour l'instant donc les trappeurs semble
davantage en voie de disparition que les
lynx
[Musique]